[Musique]
l'entrée du personnel se fait par
l'Office plus loin
j'ai mis une annonce pour recruter un
employé de maison trop la classe on
dirait un British je suis un British ça
va pas être simple qui sait ce qu'il
nous apportera
[Musique]
je cherchais de réseau et moi je fais de
la braderie avec mes guibolles et je
suis Miss France vous n'êtes pas Miss
France
vous savez monsieur steak je suis bien
content de pu être le seul homme ici
elles sont quand même spécial ces dames
[Musique]
aujourd'hui plus personne ne vient faut
toujours garder l'espoir même si on y
croit plus
pour s'éviter qu'est-ce qui se passe
entre Odile et vous vous avez déjà été
enceinte
[Musique]
de majordome
je vous ai menti
[Musique]
savez-vous pourquoi je suis ici madame
une femme que cette un jour qu'il faut
toujours garder l'espoir même si on y
croit plus
si tu parles je dépile